so guys this video is a little bit
different but I had to do it because
I've been challenged on Twitter by the
saying 17 to do the ALS challenge this
is to raise awareness for ALS and I want
to let you guys know that all ad revenue
generated by this video is going to be
donated to the fund for ALS research and
that link is in the description below my
fiance and I both took part in this
challenge because we're crazy idiots and
it was awesome so enjoy the video guys
so this is als if you guys haven't heard
of it a lot of people are doing the
bucket challenge it's to raise awareness
for it because I don't know it's crazy
and Robert Downey jr. did it so it's fun
I was challenged on Twitter by the
Saiyan 17 and he wanted me to say
something very specific before doing it
and I will I should give my fiance a
little more we are going to nominate
John Flickinger the flick pic on YouTube
and his girlfriend as well as Jake
Baldino from because video games pretty
much end game ranks and it is now
raining fuck us all let's hurry up
[Applause]
oh my god
oh my god alright so are you ready ready
alright I'm gonna say what you wanted me
to say and then I'm gonna pour it on my
head what killed the dinosaurs the Ice
Age guys donate to the cause unless you
want to be an idiot like John Flickinger
Jake Baldino and John's girlfriend we're
looking at you